in a quiet Alleyway in shanghuan
District this unassuming store offers a
window to Hong Kong's past and how
important moments in history connect
with the everyday lives of its people
this cup was distributed to kids in Hong
Kong by the colonial government during
the coronation of Queen Elizabeth II in
the 50s to encourage them to drink more
milk since the queen passed away last
year many people want to buy these cups
now
Mido opened the store nearly 20 years
ago since then he's seen his City change
and the items in his store too
I normally do not need to introduce my
products to the customers they often see
the beauty of these vintage products
which gives the sense of the old times
in recent years a series of political
and social changes including a Crackdown
on descent have also changed Hong Kong
thousands have emigrated since the end
of 2019. I have some customers who are
leaving Hong Kong and they love to
collect old furniture from government
offices but they weren't able to take
these items to other countries so they
sold it to me and in a rapidly changing
environment many young people are Keen
to learn more about the past
from cassette tapes to Old envelopes and
colonial era Cutlery shop owners say
this Rising demand for vintage products
seen as symbols of the territory's
history
some customers told Al Jazeera they're
specifically looking for items from Hong
Kong to take to their new countries I
just moved six months ago so right now
I'm in Canada so to come back here and
just like admire and appreciate some of
the Hong Kong history is very special
most people come to Ricky LA's antique
store to look for toys made in the 70s
when Hong Kong was the largest toy
manufacturer in the world
I played these toys when I was a kid I
feel emotionally connected to them they
also tell the story of old Hong Kong
there are also some customers who look
for vintage products they associate with
their childhood memories to take with
them before leaving Hong Kong for good
he says his store offers customers an
opportunity to better understand the
city's evolving identity and a chance to
be nostalgic and to carry those memories
with them wherever they go Jessica
Washington altazira Hong Kong